[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur l'île des
Impressionnistes à Chatou pour
l'électrique parc festival l'un des plus
grands festivals électro de France qui
réunit 30000 personnes chaque année ici
à Chatou il a été créé en 2010 par
Joachim garrot on va voir dans un
instant les premiers festivaliers je les
dis ils sont 30000 chaque année
[Musique]
l'ambiance c'est assez
c'est assez chill sans prise de tête
assez safe donc c'est assez agréable de
venir voilà c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
revient parce qu'en général il y a
jamais on peut toujours se poser aussi
écouter des artistes plus ou moins hard
en fonction de nos goûts artistiques moi
c'est ma première fois on vient de
Haute-Savoie
je m'attends à quoi bah à passer du bon
moment écoute ça fait des années qu'on
vient nous on passe toujours un très bon
moment électrique Park et du coup c'est
pour ça qu'on hiver tous les ans
d'accord
troisième il est très heureux DJ arrive
et les différentes scènes commencent à
s'enflammer
[Musique]
à mes côtés à le DJ fondateur de cette
électrique parc Joachim gargaro alors
Joachim c'est quoi ce festival c'est une
grosse fête en plein air sur l'île des
apprécies à Chatou ça existe depuis 14
ans c'est 5 scènes 80 artistes
30000 personnes et puis des gens
déguisés la fête à un esprit que j'aime
et que je suis très fier d'avoir réussi
à implanter ici en plein air dans ce
cadre bucolique et l'idée est venue d'où
parce que faire un festival électro dans
les Yvelines à Chatou c'est du jamais vu
alors l'idée elle est venue j'ai une
autre casquette en tant que Dj
Producteur artiste et donc j'avais fait
pas mal de tourner à l'étranger dont une
tournée en Australie où il y avait des
festivals de journées et je me suis dit
c'est ça que je vais faire je vais faire
la fête durant la journée dans un cadre
incroyable et par chance j'ai habité à
Chatou à quelques quelques centaines de
mètres d'ici et je me suis dit mais là
c'est le lieu idéal et heureusement j'ai
trouvé la mairie et la mairie m'a dit
bonne idée on fait un essai une année
après on fait un essai deux années trois
et puis maintenant ça fait 14 ans que ça
dure donc environ sur ce week-end 15000
personnes par jour ça fait quoi de voir
que le festival attire près de 30000
personnes sur un week-end ici ah ça fait
plaisir mec tu sais la première édition
on avait fait à peu près 10000 personnes
c'est pas c'est pas forcément une
question de nombreuses qui me plaît
c'est des gens qui viennent déguiser
c'est les gens qui viennent participer
qui ont compris l'esprit festif et après
le nombre ah oui ça permet de produire
des scènes encore plus grosses mais
c'est qu'un paramètre dans la fête
justement on va regarder à ces personnes
déguisées et elles sont nombreuses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça s'est fait un peu au hasard c'est
elle qui a eu l'idée et le côté
électrique park on était obligé de faire
quelque chose en rapport avec le thème
donc voilà c'est là pour ça je suis là
pour m'amuser l'électrique parc on est
là pour électrifier le bordel un peu de
folie dans ce monde dans ce monde bien
triste
[Musique]
alors ces personnes déguisées qu'est-ce
que ça vous fait on a vu un Spartacus on
a vu une personne qui avait un canard
autour d'elle que c'est normal
et vraiment je leur dédicace ce festival
parce que ils ont tout compris moi
j'aime que les spectateurs soient aussi
acteurs voilà et il y a aussi un village
aussi qui a été créé le village du coup
ça a été l'idée première ou pas de
festival aussi ouais alors les villages
étaient importants parce que ça nous
permettait de garder un petit esprit
esprit de village et de réunir des gens
qui viennent chercher des goodies et je
trouve que ça s'intègre très bien dans
le paysage de d'électric Park et puis tu
vois il y a des manèges il y a c'est
varié quoi c'est ça fait partie de la
fête justement regarder le village on a
été sur un stand on regarde tout de
suite
[Musique]
on est bien tous ensemble on retrouve
des collègues à qui on est des ventes en
event il y a autant à manger à boire des
spots sympas au filet c'est coloré c'est
très bannant on aime beaucoup donc on
peut acheter à plein de goodies c'est ça
ah bah bien sûr il y a intérêt ouais
ouais non mais c'est ça un peu on peut
acheter des choses on peut inviter des
copains à boire on peut partir en
famille on peut passer vraiment un
week-end hors du commun avec des amis et
on a essayé de tout mettre ici sur l'île
des apprenissent pour ça là on va parler
maintenant de la musique la musique j'ai
l'impression aussi que le nombre de DJ
qui veut participer à ce festival
explose oui parce que tout le monde veut
venir non mais voilà alors c'est très
important de dire que on a cinq scènes
et que je mélange un peu tous les styles
de musique pour que ça soit très varié
et je mets sur la même scène des
artistes qui sont confirmés donc des
professionnels et à côté de ça des
amateurs enfin amateurs des amateurs de
musique qui vont faire leur première
date
à Electric Park et pour moi je suis très
fier de
je pense c'est d'avoir tenu 14 ans parce
que c'est très compliqué de produire un
festival quand les gens voient ça et te
disent que tout est facile mais c'est
très très compliqué et je suis très
content d'avoir
trouvé des gens qui m'accompagnent
depuis 14 ans et d'avoir une équipe
incroyable et qu'est-ce qui reste encore
à faire ici à l'électrique Park festival
de Chatou ça continuera l'année
prochaine on sait déjà est-ce qu'il y a
encore des choses à améliorer à faire
grandir alors il y a un truc donc je
suis très fier aussi c'est qu'on est le
seul festival en Europe où les gens
peuvent venir en bateau en péniche et
j'aimerais bien l'année prochaine mettre
un peu plus de péniche et pour l'instant
on a deux péniches qui partent de Paris
qui partent du pont Bir-Hakeim et qui
remonte pendant trois heures sur la
scène pour pouvoir justement permettre
aux gens de venir en musique sur l'île
des Impressionnistes j'aimerais bien
l'année prochaine avoir plus de bateaux
comme ça j'aimerais bien aussi avoir un
jour de plus parce que si j'avais un
jour de plus ben on ferait encore plus
de style de musique voilà et vous allez
jouer aussi dans quelques instants et je
joue très rapidement c'est pour ça que
je suis un peu stressé mais ça se voit
pas c'est un plaisir toujours ah bah
ouais ouais moi c'est le jour où ça me
plaît plus j'arrête un mot peut-être
pour les festivaliers avant de se
quitter alors ben soyez les bienvenus
pour ceux qui sont déjà là merci
beaucoup rendez-vous l'année prochaine
pour ceux qui ont loupé c'est toujours
un plaisir de vous accueillir sur les
impressionnistes merci à Joachim Garraud
et nous on continue la fête
[Musique]
nous sommes maintenant aux côtés de FDA
VM qui vient tout juste de terminer à
son set ici à Chatou alors comment ça
s'est passé franchement ça porte bien
son nom c'était électrique je me suis
régalé le public j'avais au tout début
il fallait que je capte un petit peu
l'attention et en fait au bout de 10
minutes j'ai réussi à comprendre ce
qu'il voulait et c'était parfait donc tu
as mixé pendant environ une heure et
demie ça va pas trop fatigué je suis un
peu en transe mais bon c'est du plaisir
quoi je me suis je me suis marré j'ai
adoré c'était un bon moment de partage
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'était ta première fois ici à
l'électric Park qu'est-ce que tu en
penses de ce festival alors franchement
c'est un festival qui est canon mais ce
qui est assez marrant dans l'histoire
c'est que j'étais un des premiers à
écouter Joachim Garraud et le fait que
ce soleil qui viennent à la fin pour
m'annoncer mais c'est en hommage j'étais
un peu impressionné j'étais trop content
et ça s'est passé comment justement les
échanges avec Joachim Garros c'est lui
qui est venu te chercher ça s'est passé
comment c'est lui qui est venu me
chercher c'est lui qui est venu
m'annoncer c'est lui qui est venu me
féliciter et maintenant j'aimerais moi à
mon tour aller le remercier parce que il
m'a fait confiance et je pense que il a
eu raison donc c'était à première fois
ici et tu as grandi enfin tu as grandi
tu as été trois ans à côté à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye tu as vécu à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pendant 3 ans tu
es à domicile en fait finalement j'ai
passé mon bac j'ai passé mon bac je suis
lillois de base mais effectivement je
suis venu grandir dans les Yvelines à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et effectivement
j'avais pas mal de potes du Vésinet de
Chatou etc qui sont venus en me disant
ça fait ça fait quelques années flocons
t'as pas vu on est plutôt impressionné
de te voir et euh j'ai pas changé je
reste le même je vis de ma passion et je
suis très content d'être sur ce festival
aujourd'hui il est comment du coup ce
public de l'électrique Park et il est
chaud et les choses j'avais un peu peur
avec le temps aussi au départ et on a
été gâté et franchement c'est un public
qui a envie de faire la fête et je vais
moi-même à monter à aller faire la fête
avec alors il y a beaucoup de DJ à très
connus qui viennent ici Robin Schulz par
exemple qui va mixer ce soir ce vendredi
soir qu'est-ce que ça te fait toi de
côtoyer des DJ hyper reconnus alors en
fait j'ai la chance de les croiser sur
pas mal d'événements notamment
Ibiza et cetera je suis tout le temps
quasiment avec Offenbach et oui j'ai eu
la chance de tous les rencontrer j'ai
mon ami Boris qui va venir Boris way et
c'est juste en fait franchement ça fait
plaisir c'est tout le temps une petite
réunion de se voir on se parle de nos
actus et puis ça permet d'échanger on
est tout le temps en tout on se parle
toujours sur internet mais au bout d'un
moment c'est cool de se voir et de
passer un peu de temps de dîner etc
c'est finalement un festival très
familial très très familial puisque en
fait c'est allo Floride qui qui partage
les bookings avec Joachim et c'est mon
agence de booking donc je suis super
content franchement qui me fait
confiance pour l'occasion racontons-nous
un petit peu ton parcours dans le dans
le monde des DJ
alors moi ça fait 15 ans que je suis
dans la musique à la base j'étais
organisateur d'événements puis DJ puis
producteur nous étions deux FDVM donc
moi c'est le FD il y avait un VM dans
l'histoire c'était mon meilleur ami et
c'est toujours un de mes supers amis
parce que je lui envoie toujours les
productions et ça fait trois ans
maintenant que je suis seul et je viens
de signer sur le label de Warner je suis
super content ça se passe super bien
j'ai mon prochain single sortira au mois
d'octobre alors tu as fait des gros
festivals comme Coachella aux États-Unis
Tomorrowland quand on voit ce festival
là est-ce que quand même il y a il y a
des petites choses qu'on retrouve dans
ces festivals oui oui bah comme dans
chaque festival mais pour être honnête
il y a une vraie French Touch qu'on
retrouve ici qu'on retrouvera pas
ailleurs et puis même au niveau au
niveau de l'organisation il y a toujours
un petit sourire un petit chèque etc et
ça fait toujours plaisir alors
l'événement existe depuis 2010 ils
grandit d'année en année est-ce que toi
tu as envie de faire partie aussi de
cette histoire tu as déjà fait partie de
cette histoire aujourd'hui mais est-ce
que tu pourrais t'inscrire dans le temps
ici à Electric Park à grand plaisir pour
être honnête avec et qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'un 7 est réussi selon toi
quand on a tous les bras levés à la fin
c'est la base un mot peut-être qui
définirait cette électrique Park de
Chatou
l'énergie l'énergie il faut dire un mot
s'il faut dire une phrase c'est merci à
ce public qui est venu qui me
connaissait peut-être pas à la base et
qui maintenant me connaît tu reviendras
l'année prochaine avec grand plaisir
merci à toi FDM merci il ne reste plus
que deux heures premier bilan de la
journée pour le 15000 festivaliers
[Musique]
de rencontrer les gens les gens sont
tellement adorables la musique ça réunit
et c'est incroyable
il y a pas cherché meilleur festival de
des Yvelines c'est ouf c'est dans le
coeur ça fait 5 ans que je le fais c'est
magique cette festival c'est magique
j'adore le son j'adore l'ambiance les
gens ils sont cool on vient avec nos
potes depuis 5 ans et il y a rien à dire
c'est toujours extraordinaire j'habite
juste à côté donc tout le temps tous les
tous les ans on y va et d'être avec tous
mes potes ça fait grand plaisir et de
rencontrer du monde etc c'est génial
voilà
je suis pas fan d'électro de base mais
le fait d'être tous ensemble entre amis
etc ça donne envie de venir du coup je
viens voilà
première soirée incroyable je pense que
c'est à peu près le même retour que tu
dois avoir de tout le monde non
[Musique]
l'électrique Park de Chatou c'est
bientôt terminé pour nous il reviendra à
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition et Joachim Garraud l'a dit ça
sera encore plus fou ça sera encore plus
fort moi je vais profiter du set de
Robin Schulz avant que ça se termine
[Musique]